[Music]
I can't pay rent with these things one's
a pumpkin and these Asgardian coins
they're not worth it in Asgard those
coins these coins are worth gazillion
human dollars okay there's a gazillion
you're rich there's a gazillion zillion
be silly I said no one will exchange
these go to the market set up a store
Yeah right
yeah Asgardian where previously owned by
four I'm a celebrity that will sell like
hotcakes you might need to think about
getting a getting a job good job suits
yeah I have a job no my job is I saved
the planet did maybe you should get a
job
hmm I have a job really cheating the
machine with the words that come out of
it this is knowledge knowledge is power
no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power the brain is a muscle and
that's a muscle and that's a muscle
there you're all muscles this is all
muscle so I am covered in brains and I'm
more brains than you so do you think
maybe we could just think about when you
deserve it I don't think we can get a
surgeon get a service a day we could
settle we're getting a Sabbath Marvel's
Doctor Strange on digital in blu-ray is
the new crafter electronic letter and
writing to Captain America and Iron Man
there seems to be something very intense
going on between them and I want to
offer my help with my services dear